the fight against the corona virus
affects all parts of the European
economy one of the sectors where we will
tolerate no disruption whatsoever is
that of food despite these challenging
times we make sure that Europeans
continue to have access to high-quality
affordable food that's why early on in
the current crisis we took measures to
ensure that goods including food flow in
the single market and that seasonal
workers can still travel to other
countries to plant or harvest our crops
I would like to thank our farmers who
make sure that food is available in our
shops and I'm grateful to the thousands
of European citizens who are
volunteering to help with this year's
harvest this is a wonderful example of
European solidarity but farmers need
more help and this is why we take
several new measures to support them
today we will give farmers more time to
submit their applications for direct
payments and Rural Development payments
and we will soon increase the advances
of these payments to give them more cash
up front to pay their bills
we will also simplify certain
administrative requirements for farmers
and for national administrations because
they have more urgent priorities these
days than fill in papers and we will
make it easier to support medical
facilities in rural areas through the
Rural Development Fund we stand by our
farmers in these challenging days we
will take further action to support them
as the situation evolves